when did you realize you could make a
living doing action films in Mexico you
know the first film you know was a
relatively larger film so
um I kind of knew right away you know I
knew that
that as long as we could come in with
the lower budget and provide uh the look
that people wanted there would be
constant work there
I recognized that relatively early
um
where I was not convinced was when I was
trying to be a writer producer in LA and
you know this this thing comes up and
somebody says hey I got a project and I
got some guy with money and you have
these meetings and that never works out
you know and but when I got to Mexico I
realized uh this is absolutely something
that people need you know we can blow up
a car in the street we can do chases
through the streets without much problem
at all and I know that you can't do that
in LA and I realize that
um as far as buyers and what it takes to
um sell a film they want action a lot of
the time it's the easiest thing to sell
for Distributors and if we can give you
know relatively high quality action
films that have a nice big production
value at a very very low cost with you
know kind of
lower
risk you know less permits less all that
stuff then that would pretty much always
be work for us and we've had dry spells
um but there's always somebody calling
and saying hey you know I got a film
it's based in Mexico
um what do you think
and they and you know
but we always usually say you know let's
read the script and we'll see how we
think we can work it out but we usually
try to say yes you know we we're not
really afraid of
um any of the film challenges uh or
budgetary challenges we try to say yes
on on most things unless we feel that
it's not a good fit you know as far as
uh uh you know
Dynamic wise unless we feel like these
people might be problematic
um
or they you know maybe they want too
much for you know they don't have enough
things of that sort but if if things
work out you know we try to we try to do
as much as we can you know stay working
you know just just keep it going don't
there's you know that's what we do you
know and and a lot of people are trying
to find the work you know they're
they're every day you know they're
they're on the phone there are coffee
shops they're making taking meetings and
we just kind of keep just chugging along
and so
um so yeah it would it would have been
kind of toward the beginning I I always
felt like this is something that because
I know enough about Hollywood to know
that this is something that's absolutely
needed you know to be able to make a
film
uh for the a lower price and get a
bigger production value go 360. get the
filmmaker if it's not me and give this
filmmaker a 360 View at something
because you know you can't do that on
Hollywood Boulevard without you know
but I can do it in Revolution Boulevard
and and TJ
can you explain why the movie business
isn't pure art
um no it's not at all I mean if you
learn that one you learn that quick too
um
you know in fact move your business and
certainly directing is not art directing
is and I don't know
um how the scholars look at it but I
consider it craft
more than it is Art you're putting
you're putting people together and
things together to create an outcome
a product
um
the the film business is truly a
business because you learn this and one
of the things you learn when you get
your first film into the market is
especially an independent film is all
the bad news that you get about how the
film's not selling like it was supposed
to
um it wasn't we're supposed to sell this
much that they tell you on this
this sheet that you think I'm going to
be rich and it didn't sell that amount
and of course it's always our fault
um the filmmaker's fault but you realize
that you know
uh in order to make the films the films
have to be collateralized
um it's like any other product anything
is collateralized so and so what is the
film Colorado's bias collateralized by
its unsold territories
and it's it's so they think it's worth a
million dollars they'll give you 500 000
I think it's worth five million they'll
give you 2 million so forth and so on
and so
when you approach
that side of it the more you know about
that the better because if you go in
there blind about that like oh you know
what this is going to be the next
Tarantino movie or something and people
really don't care about that they really
care about how can I collateralize it
how can I make sure that if I put in 2
million
I'm gonna get out this much money what
collateralizes it and it collateralized
obviously by the subject matter but
that's minimal these days it's about the
actor
that's how you collateralize it so you
realize it's it's it's a business of
collateralization
and if you can collateralize
you come to them with the collateral we
can do this movie with this person for
this much
they do their calculus and you can keep
working
if you go and say hey I wrote this
amazing script
and my friends from acting class are
going to be in it and they're the
they're the best
pure art well
if you have a rich Uncle Maybe but if
you take it into where the money is
because the money is in finance and
Banks and things like that and they'll
collateralize any if I mean if it's
collateralized they'll Finance anything
so if you can show that you learn in the
process to show that you understand that
and it doesn't you always don't even
have to have the collateral if they know
that you know it
as a filmmaker they trust you more
because you're not just out there on
cloud nine trying to make
Some Kind of Wonderful piece of art that
everybody can look at but no one can
figure out a way to get any kind of
return on
so so that probably doesn't happen with
the first or second film
correct no not that I know from I mean
my first film was going to be this big
piece of art
um and it was written that way
I think now
we could have commercialized it a little
bit more we had some pretty artistic
themes in it
um
but I liked art too I I would love to
get to the point where it was art for me
and I could step back a little bit from
the business and just say hey let's just
do something that's just really really
good
you know we have this saying like
because
any anytime you do action films
um that are not
X-Men or fast and furious or Die Hard
you know they dog them it's the the in
the in because people aren't forgiving
about that they say look an action scene
is an action scene they have uh
30 days and 15 million dollars to do it
you have
before lunch and five thousand dollars
to do it they don't care they just want
the action scene to be right
um but I always say if you ever really
want to get great
reviews just take the action out
student talking in art films and and
just have people uh you know talking to
each other and and make it interesting
and and people will love it it's the
it's the action that has to sell
and
and it's very hard to do that on low
budgets you learn that and and you have
to take your hits in in your in the
reviews and things like that I don't
really look at reviews but
but you but you realize that that's what
it is that it's it's not if people don't
forgive you know they don't they it's
just like a comedy you can make any kind
of Comedy you want but are you is it
funny
that's all people care about is it funny
it do a film they don't they could do a
film in a small room a small house but
is it scary you know and so
um you know
at the end of the day
it's art and it's a mixture of Art and
commerce but
you know my goal is to get to the more
artistic stuff and step back from the
business because it definitely colors
the way that you film it colors the way
you shoot and it colors the way that you
um approach your filmmaking
Journey I'd rather it be more art
say that producers want more action and
the director wants less
you know that's that's a good question
you know
I would say the producers all meaning
the the financiers Distributors want
more action that's for sure
as far as the producer's side they just
want to
you know bring it in on budget and get
it done as efficiently as possible and
get it out and get it
um do their job Distributors and and and
sales agents want more action for sure
as far as me as a director for example
I would prefer to have less action
unless it's super motivated
meaning it
it has to mean something I don't want to
if I'm if I'm trying to get to the door
um
if I'm trying to get out the door and
there's a guy in front of me I have to
do this this that to get to the door
that's the kind of action I don't want
to sit in here and fight just to fight
and just break things and everything it
has to be motivated so as long as it has
a motive that's motivated within the
larger story then action is great but
action for the sake of action unless
it's done in this huge way that's so
interesting to look at like in X-Men and
things like that where it's just so
interesting to sit back and just enjoy
it
um I would prefer to have less action
as a director
but even let's say sicario if I think
back to it there were Quiet Moments
there was Stillness and that's what made
some of the action even even greater
that's correct sicario Man on Fire
movies like that
um it's it's much more about the story
um it's much more about the characters
and the relationships
and the action then is more intense when
you care about the people as you know
and so it when the story Stakes are high
when the character Stakes are high then
that one punch is a lot more
impactful than it would be is if you
don't care about the character or if
they just show up you know an old Hong
Kong movies people just rotated and out
you know you know to to beat the guy up
you know so so we have
um
a lot of different ways to skin that cat
as far as making sure that it's
motivated but I do absolutely you know
want to make sure that it's motivated
and if given the opportunity I would
love to make films uh that have less
action in them but people come to Mexico
they they want to do explosions and
things like that so we we do them as
much as possible and try to make it
interesting and keep it within the story
as a distributor ever said we can't
pre-sell this territory unless there's
this this and this type of fighting or
scene or absolutely oh okay yeah tell me
that all the time they say
um uh it needs to have this much action
in it and uh page 10 needs to have this
happen page 20 needs to have that happen
well so we we write them that way now we
just pack them in with action so and
then sometimes we don't shoot everything
we we try but I mean you can only shoot
what you can what you can get to but
sometimes you know we do the best we can
but if there's just nothing but pure
action in The Script then you have to
think well if the guy is going to go
from from the coffee shop to the
restaurant
you know maybe he'll just have to kill
instead of the eight people that it says
in the script maybe you can kill five
you know stuff like that it still has
the same thing but but it but you have
to you know compromise and make sure
that you can actually get it done with
your resources and make it still make it
good I think the key to being a good
action director
is understanding your resources you know
you you can't have no money and then
want to do a big car flip it's just not
going to look right so you say well
instead of doing a car flip let's make
it crash into the tree
and it's really the same thing
um and but sometimes it's not to the
Distributors but it but you can get but
you just don't have the money to do the
car flip so so you have to make the you
have to cut make certain compromises and
as long as you can make it and give it
the same energy and give it the same
um give it the same punch in the in the
in the project in the movie then it
usually is okay but we do try to do is
we do try to follow the script as much
as possible but you know sometimes
action can be a little gratuitous too
you know just especially when it's in
Mexico there's just cartels coming at
you Thug one Thug two bad guy one big
guy three you know all these people
coming at you and it begins to look like
you're shooting zombies or something so
we try to make sure you know when you
get to set you're looking at it and say
if the guy can get from there to there
he can take out these three guys and
punch this guy and get out it doesn't
have to be 15 guys all the time so we
look at it and make sure that it looks
right
what about for the opening how is it
something immediate you've got to see
something blow up or something happen
well I think you know that in any kind
of story structure
um which I'm not an expert although I am
a writer and I've written the first
films that we did
um you have to you know create something
that brings people in you know and it
doesn't always have to be an explosion
or an action scene that's sometimes
that's nice but it has to you know
create a question
that people want to sit around and wait
to find out the answer
so sometimes that can be in the form of
action it's all of a sudden you see a
guy bam it gets shot he falls down and
then he you know guys and then you've
got to figure out okay why did I get
shot and fall down and then that's what
our story is about it's it's telling us
and informing us of what may have
happened in that first scene but I will
tell you that in script stock structure
things do have to happen within the
first 10 pages minimum 20 pages
or you will lose people
um we're in a a
you know
era and an age where people scrub
three-minute videos they're like this is
too long uh YouTube
you know so you have to grab people's
attention and keep it with it's but you
can do that in a lot of ways with
compelling story with the question with
a with a
with something but you know you can't
just kind of just float in to the film
unless you you know have some great
actor that you can't take your eyes off
you know that you know that you maybe
you'll follow them for a little bit
longer if you're doing a kind of a lower
budget action film you have to you have
to bring them in right away
but there has to be some resting points
okay it can't just be all because
they're then then nothing uh you can't
measure anything against you're
absolutely right
um I'm big on that
because
the film has to breathe
you got to be able to sit back and
take in what you're seeing and see where
it means in the overall story
you can't just have this thing where
you're where you're just constantly
being bombarded with with
um you know different things that are
like action-based things you have to
take a minute to sit back and let the
character sit back and reflect and
contemplate and figure out
whatever
way that they're getting into whatever
they got into they have to figure out a
way out of it I always tell an actor
it's interesting it's it's pretty much
Universal they'll go right into
they'll be told something or they'll
they'll hear a gunshot and then they'll
go do something I said always
allow yourself to react to it like it's
foreign to you bam gunshot
take a second this bam gunshot and they
run
you'd say no just take a minute
and let it register what's happened
then run let register what they just
told you
then respond to it
because they've been reading the script
and doing it on coverage 10 times so
they just can react but let it
let it sink in and I think you can do
that with the with the storyline in
total you have to let things sink in a
little bit so it gives people time to
care gives people time to
um in time and space and emotional space
too to to to make their decision on
whether they like the character who they
want to win who they hate you know how
much they hate them and figure out you
know go along with you and try to figure
out the story themselves and then you
can
kind of like
you know kind of get there together
with you and the audience at the same
time